-Elle s'est révélée au public
pendant la campagne présidentielle
comme porte-parole de Marine Le Pen,
mais son engagement
remonte aux années 90.
Mon invitée
a de l'énergie à revendre,
et une foi inébranlable.
Générique
...
Bonjour Laure Lavalette.
-Bonjour Clément.
-Vous êtes catholique,
vous ne le cachez pas.
La foi est importante
dans votre vie.
A la dernière rentrée
parlementaire,
vous avez assisté à cette messe
consacrée aux parlementaires,
en la basilique Sainte-Clotilde.
A cette occasion,
vous avez comparé l'engagement
politique et la charité.
Pour vous, la quête du bien commun,
c'est aussi une sorte
de charité suprême.
La recherche du bien commun,
c'est la charité due à son peuple.
Vous seriez-vous engagée
en politique
si vous n'aviez pas eu cette foi,
cette foi catholique ?
-Sûrement,
mais c'est difficile de savoir.
Je suis catholique depuis longtemps
dans une famille catholique.
Mais quand j'étais déléguée
de classe en 4e,
vous imaginez bien
que c'était pas lié à ma foi.
-Vous faites quand même un lien ?
-Si j'y réfléchis, bien sûr.
Je pense
qu'il y a une forme de charité.
Y a une forme de sacerdoce
quand on voit le temps que ça prend.
C'est un engagement plein et entier,
qui engage aussi sa famille,
ce qui n'est pas simple.
Oui, y a une forme
de charité,
la recherche du bien commun.
Quand on s'engage en politique,
on est amoureux du bien commun.
Même mes adversaires politiques
sont amoureux du bien commun,
même si nous ne partageons
pas la même définition
de ce bien commun.
Après, vous savez,
la foi, dans ma vie,
j'étais à la messe de rentrée,
je n'y suis pas retournée depuis.
C'est trop tôt.
-Les religions portent
un regard sur la société,
ce qui peut les amener à intervenir
dans le débat public.
Le 9 octobre 2022,
à l'occasion de la messe
de canonisation d'un évêque italien,
le pape François a pris la parole.
Ecoutons.
(en italien)
*-L'exclusion des migrants,
est criminelle.
Cela les fait mourir devant nous.
Et cela fait aujourd'hui
de la Méditerranée
le plus grand cimetière du monde.
L'exclusion des migrants
est dégoûtante.
C'est un péché, c'est criminel.
-En tant qu'élue du RN,
vous défendez une politique
migratoire restrictive.
Et en tant que catholique,
vous avez le pape François
qui vous enjoint d'accueillir
et de venir en aide
aux migrants.
Comment conciliez-vous les deux,
votre foi
et vos convictions politiques ?
-Quand le pape François nous exhorte
à une charité personnelle,
il est tout à fait dans son rôle.
Après...
-Pour vous, il s'adresse...
-...à la hauteur
d'un pays, il faut rendre à César
ce qui lui appartient,
ça n'est pas vraiment de son fait.
Il s'immisce
dans la souveraineté des pays.
Le peuple français doit décider
de sa politique migratoire.
C'est pour cela
que nous voulions un referendum.
Je dirais au pape François
que Saint Augustin en parlait déjà,
il disait :
"Comme on ne peut pas s'occuper
"de tout le monde, il faut s'occuper
de celui qui est le plus proche,
"comme lié par un sort avec vous.
Le plus proche
"par les circonstances,
le lieu ou le temps."
Quand on voit
la situation de la France,
les gens dont on doit s'occuper
en premier, ce sont les Français.
Je le déplore, car...
J'ai eu à me positionner
sur l'Ocean Viking
qui a abordé
dans le port militaire de Toulon.
-Dans votre circonscription.
-Evidemment, il faut secourir
ces migrants qui sont en mer.
Faire en sorte qu'ils ne prennent
plus des risques inconsidérés
et mettre fin à ces ONG
qui sont complices des passeurs.
Je reprendrai les mots
du cardinal Sarah
qui dit que c'est là-bas
qu'il faut les aider.
Chacun a vocation
à s'épanouir sur la terre.
-Le pape doit éviter la politique ?
-Il n'a pas à faire de politique.
Mais il doit nous exhorter
à une charité individuelle.
Celle-là, je ne la remets pas
du tout en cause.
Je me suis émue du sort
des enfants mineurs
qui sont arrivés de l'Ocean Viking,
que la protection de l'enfance
a mis dans un hôtel,
et au bout de 48h,
ils avaient tous disparu.
J'en ai parlé
au Conseil départemental
On les a mis en danger.
-Un autre sujet, où l'église est
intervenue dans le champ politique,
c'est l'opposition
au mariage pour tous.
Quelle est la différence entre
la question des migrants
et celle du mariage pour tous ?
L'intervention de l'Eglise
est plus légitime ?
-C'est différent.
Et encore une fois,
je pense que l'Eglise...
Pour avoir été dans les manifs,
c'était pas une procession.
-Non, mais l'évêque de Toulon
a appelé à la mobilisation
contre la loi Taubira.
-Que les évêques, les papes parlent,
c'est très bien.
C'est aux politiques
d'en faire ce qu'ils veulent.
C'est très différent
par rapport à...
Comment dire...
A la politique migratoire.
Je pensais que c'était un changement
de civilisation qui n'allait pas
dans la mesure
où le mariage
ne doit pas célébrer l'amour,
mais célébrer la fondation
d'une famille avec une descendance.
Encore une fois, une natalité aussi
qui permet au pays
de bien vivre.
C'est important pour un enfant de
savoir qu'il a un père et une mère.
Ce serait mentir
de dire le contraire.
Il a forcément une gamète
du sexe différent.
-Parlons de votre engagement au FN.
Vous vous êtes engagée
vers l'âge de 15 ans.
-J'ai eu une carte
de façon anecdotique à 16 ans.
-Pourquoi cet engagement ?
-Mon papa s'était déjà présenté,
et fait 2 élections législatives.
-Jean-Philippe Lavalette
s'est présenté 2 fois.
Il a été présent au FN
dès sa création.
-Oh trop drôle !
-En 1972. Avant il faisait partie
du mouvement d'extrême droite
Ordre Nouveau.
-Oui, c'était un autre...
un autre contexte.
Quand on dit ça maintenant,
quand vous dites extrême droite,
c'était un moment,
en mai 68, où tout était exacerbé.
Mais il a toujours eu à coeur
de préserver
la souveraineté de son pays.
-Vous avez eu
un engagement syndical,
à la fac de droit
de Bordeaux. Vous avez présidé
la section du Renouveau Etudiant,
qui, à l'époque,
était un syndicat proche
du Front National.
Récemment, "L'Express" a révélé
que ces années d'engagement syndical
ont été marquées
par des actions violentes,
sur le campus de Bordeaux.
La presse régionale de l'époque
s'en est fait l'écho plusieurs fois,
relatant des incidents violents
impliquant votre syndicat,
évoquant des expéditions punitives
menées par des personnes
liées à votre syndicat,
même des membres de votre syndicat.
Marteaux, battes de baseball,
des gaz lacrymogènes.
Vous assumez ?
-Il faut remettre les choses
dans leur contexte.
C'était en 1997, 1996.
Où il y avait effectivement
de la violence sur les fac.
A tel point
que les renseignements territoriaux
faisaient un focus sur ce moment,
car c'était révélateur
des tensions que
l'on trouvait dans la société.
Y avait le local de l'UNEF
à côté du nôtre,
et c'était un peu tendu.
Je pense que ce...
Cet article du stagiaire
de "L'Express" essaye
de me faire passer pour un skinhead.
Personne n'est dupe.
-En 1998, cet engagement politique
s'est concrétisé
par votre 1re candidature
aux cantonales.
-Là, vous sortez le dossier...
-Voilà, c'est ça.
Vous aviez 22 ans à l'époque,
vous étiez étudiante.
Ca vous a valu des remarques ?
Des attaques ?
-Non, mais de planter mon année !
coller des affiches et faire des
marchés, vous êtes pas sur votre TD.
Non, ça m'a pas valu de remarques.
Je crois que j'étais la femme...
Je pense que j'étais
la plus jeune de France,
au sein du FN ou carrément
de tous les candidats.
C'était une sacrée expérience.
A Bègles.
J'ai quand même fait 10,33 %.
C'était assez fou. C'était une belle
expérience
militante.
-Dans ce parcours,
juste après, il y a eu une forme
d'écart, d'infidélité
au Front National,
à l'époque, c'était le FN.
Vous avez quitté le FN
pour suivre Bruno Mégret au MNR.
Pourquoi ?
-Je pense qu'on avait envie
de dédiabolisation.
On avait envie...
On était lassés des provocations
de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
Quand vous passiez
vos nuits à coller,
et que le lendemain,
il faisait une bourde à la radio...
-C'est l'idée
de l'union des droites aussi ?
-C'était l'idée de dédiabolisation.
De se dire qu'on allait gagner,
qu'on voulait le pouvoir.
Avec un peu de recul, je me dis
qu'il avait pas un charisme de fou.
Ce qui est assez marrant,
c'est de se dire
que ce que j'avais cherché au MNR,
c'est Marine Le Pen
qui me l'a offert
avec sa vision du RN.
-Vous avez
fait une pause
pour fonder votre famille.
5 enfants.
Dont une fille qui est trisomique.
Vous êtes très engagée
sur les questions
de handicap.
En tant que député,
vous avez l'espoir de pouvoir
améliorer les politiques publiques
sur ce sujet ?
-J'aimerais. Ce qui a pas mal
marqué mon engagement...
Quand Marine me demande
d'être porte-parole en charge
du handicap, évidemment, j'accepte.
Ce qui a bien marché,
c'est que je vis
le quotidien des Français.
Avec 5 enfants,
une fille handicapée, on sait
qu'il y a 6 mois d'attente dans les
dossiers à la Maison départementale
des personnes handicapées. Je sais
que Parcours Sup marche pas.
Parler aux gens
de ce qui les concerne et le vivre,
ça vous enracine.
Et c'est ce qui a fait
que les Français
m'aiment bien,
ceux que je rencontre.
Ils aiment cette proximité
que j'ai avec eux.
Si je pouvais améliorer les choses
pour le handicap, ce serait super.
-Pour revenir
à cette question du handicap,
vous avez dit que l'engagement
prenait du temps sur la famille.
Comment gère-t-on cela
quand on a un enfant qui a besoin
d'un peu plus d'attention.
-C'est pas très simple.
C'est une vraie question.
Ma chance, c'est qu'elle est
relativement autonome.
C'est plus simple.
On se rend compte qu'on est aidant.
Les frères et soeurs
aident davantage.
C'est moi qui l'amenais
et allais la chercher.
Ils ont pris
le relais naturellement.
Je me fais aider
quand j'en ai besoin.
C'est une vraie question.
Ca veut dire que beaucoup de gens
sont aidants sans s'en apercevoir.
Je me suis jamais dit
que moi ou mes enfants
étions aidants.
Je suis pas avec ma famille,
ça fait 3 jours que je suis à Paris,
il faut que le reste tourne.
Et la famille est fondamentale.
C'est 11 millions d'aidants
qui sont déclarés.
Donc, comme moi,
certains ne le savent pas.
-C'est l'heure de notre quizz.
Je vous explique...
-Vous commencez une phrase ?
-Exactement, vous connaissez.
Donc une phrase que vous complétez.
Vous êtes porte-parole
du groupe RN à l'Assemblée.
Le secret pour être bon,
c'est...
-Rester naturel,
rester un peu insolente,
beaucoup travailler,
et surtout continuer
à aimer les Français.
-En arrivant à l'Assemblée,
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que...
-Ce soit aussi exaltant.
Et aussi passionnant.
-Que du positif ?
Pas de mauvaises surprises ?
-Non, c'est une chance folle
d'être dans cette maison magnifique.
Ca honore, ça oblige d'être là
et de représenter
les Français.
C'est une grande joie.
-J'aurais réussi mon mandat si...
-J'ai déjà l'impression
d'y être un peu arrivée.
J'ai porté la cause d'Emma.
jeune fille polyhandicapée
sur ma circonscription,
qui avait été mise
à la porte de son établissement
comme 17 autres familles.
D'avoir parlé d'Emma directement
au ministre Combe, en commission
Affaires sociales, je me suis dit :
"Même si ça s'arrête, je regrette
pas d'être venue pour Emma."
-Merci, Laure Lavalette.
-Merci, Clément Méric.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...